Jessica in Michigan you're on the bench
Pierre I shall go fart Jessica hi Ben
thank you for taking my call today I own
a real estate company here in Clarkston
Michigan as you've probably heard there
is some protest yesterday at the Capitol
I was one of them I didn't I left
Iommi held out to be on the lawn I
didn't go into the building I was really
calling because I owned a real estate
company and in 48 states and not
including Michigan Realtors are
essential in Michigan appraisers aren't
essential inspectors are essential title
companies are essential and mortgage
companies are essential so everyone
except for realtors is essential so our
client who literally can't buy a house
right now and are homeless living with
friends because we can't take them to go
look at houses and so I was really
curious if you think that if I defied
the order and got a ticket for that or
got arrested or got a misdemeanor which
is the threat do you think that that
would uphold in court that it's now been
eight weeks that I've been trapped in my
home the government has given me
literally nothing because they said that
I made too much money last year to be
eligible I can't continue to decide
between paying my mortgage or paying my
groceries what what would happen if I
got arrested yep so let's let's talk
about that and I have questions about
how the protest went exactly
you only see the media coverage so I'd
be curious to hear how it went out on
the lawn so first of all yeah if you got
a ticket for defying the order the high
likelihood is that it would hold up in
lower court and then you'd have to
elevate it all the way up to the federal
courts and say that your federal civil
rights have been violated that there is
no good rational basis reason why
realtor should not be allowed to work
yeah I think that if you elevated it to
the federal level there's a good chap
that you'd be able to beat the
misdemeanor ticket the problems would
cost you so much money to go to a lawyer
to beat the misdemeanor ticket that's
basically what what burr is betting on
what she's betting on is you don't have
the resources or the will to drag that
out for a process that'll be a year long
to avoid $1,000 ticket so
you'll either just pay the thousand
dollar ticket or you won't and that'll
be that and she's probably right I mean
for most people that is indeed the case
the fact is that there can be no
rational basis for everybody except for
Realtors gets to work right now I mean
it's just this is insane I mean it is
totally insane these governors are
picking essential businesses and they're
doing it almost out of a hat
they're almost just declaring certain
businesses essential and certain
business is not essential not on the
basis of any rationale but based simply
on going down a check boxed
list and then randomly selecting from
the from the Chinese menu it's it's
totally wild so I think you have a very
solid case I mean you should talk to a
federal civil rights lawyer if that's
something you're interested in doing but
honestly I don't see how that holds up
in federal court like on a roll level
now don't take my my legal advice as the
purest form of good advice here you
should talk to somebody who's more
expert than I but it seems like even
rational basis review would not be able
to uphold the distinction between a
realtor and appraiser in in essential
business again I think that whitmer is
gonna have to start releasing people
from this lock down sooner rather than
later I would be surprised if she
continues to lock down for another month
in the way that she has so far although
she is running for vice-president and
she's gotten all sorts of media
attention for for doing it so you never
know the political considerations are
really bad so Jessica tell me about the
protest yesterday because all we saw
from the media obviously were the people
who actually went inside the Capitol my
understanding is they were temperature
checked I don't have a problem with
people showing up with guns per the law
but it seems to me bad optics to get up
in the face of cops and scream at cops
and get in people's faces without masks
it's it seems to be sort of the opposite
of what people are promoting which is I
can run my business responsibly without
providing a danger to others to do all
of that what was it like outside the
capital as you well know Ben the
pictures that you're seeing on the
Internet are are not really describing
what actually happened yesterday one
thing that I was really impressed by was
how the media intentionally didn't say
that sheriff Clark was there speaking to
the crowd which I had no idea what's
going to happen I had no idea if the
protest is still going on because
Facebook removed all ads in Lee in
relation to it so I honestly went as a
Republican as a conservative and as a
business owner I'm impressed with how
real Republicans have time to protest
after you take away their job so I know
that others people need to have a lot of
time to process but since I can't work I
have nothing to do but to protest this
measure so I was there I was standing on
the lawn
the police were walking completely
through the crowd the Michigan State
Police was walking there everyone was
standing on the lawn you know probably
maybe not six feet apart but every you
know household was standing in a clump
and the police were walking through the
crowd safely it's not honest that people
were screaming in the faces of cops if
you take a picture from the side which
is where that picture of what looks like
men screaming in places in the faces of
cops um you can't tell how far apart
he's clearly standing in between them
and so I had a conversation with the
police officer while I was there and I
said not one person in this whole crowd
has facts better pigs wearing top hats
on it these are the people who are
defending the police so while you're
deciding who to give a ticket which as
far as I know no one got a ticket
yesterday just know that these are the
people who are kneeling for the flag I
am a cop's wife I love the police but my
husband didn't take an oath to protect
Gretchen Whitmer he took an oath to
protect the Constitution and that is his
job and I am very sure that the police
that were there yesterday if anyone ever
asked them they would say that the crowd
was completely under control that no one
was disrespectful to the police and that
has nothing to do with what the media is
saying happened I haven't found one
article about the fact that the sheriff
I think from Minnesota sheriff Clark was
there giving a speech telling people to
stop to stand up for their rights
well Jessica really appreciate the call
and as I say I think a lot of protesters
who are actually being response about
how they're protesting are getting
lumped in with that the people that the
media can make out to be the the not so
there they're basically involved in what
we call in the media nut picking which
is they're finding the people or the
most inflammatory they're making that
out to be the majority of these crowds
that is not what I'm perceiving from a
lot of people from whom I am receiving
email so Jessica really appreciate the
colony information Justin in
Pennsylvania you're on the bench pure
before Justin I know not to belittle
anything that's going on another state
especially Jessica in Michigan there
sounds like a lot worse than in PA but I
haven't heard a lot about college
students during this whole ordeal which
is interesting to me because most of us
were excluded from the stimulus we're
either just out of the age range where
our parents you can get to five hundred
we didn't get any money and we're out of
jobs of course like 30 million other
people but I'm just curious what you
think that the situation should be there
because again most of us are really
gotten shortchanged and we got nothing
to do nowhere to go and I go to a trade
school how am I supposed to do virtual
stuff when all my work is hands-on so I
you know I'll be honest with you I don't
know if the if cowed students are even
eligible for a stimulus check I believe
that college students under the cares
Act are ineligible between 17 and 23 if
their claims as a dependent on somebody
else's federal income taxes most how
students are still classified as
dependents for purposes of federal aid
or to continue having medical coverage
that's the big problem so I'm not sure
about your particular story used to
claim are you still claimed as a
dependent by members of your family I
believe yeah so I mean that that would
be the issue there so if your if you're
not claimed as a dependent then you're
eligible for aid if you're claimed as a
dependent then the government is going
to assume you're an actual dependent
meaning that your parents are paying
your bills it's one of the the traps
that is sort of set in the law is that
you sometimes our claim as a dependent
by your parents and they're not actually
supporting you they just want to keep
you going on their health insurance so
you don't have to pay for your own
health insurance it's one of the
problems with Obamacare which really
should not have allowed people to remain
dependent on their parents health care
beyond the age of 18 right once you're
an adult you should be paying for your
own health insurance so people took
advantage of that and it set up this
perverse incentive where you claimed
your kid as a dependent for purposes of
health insurance but they're not
actually a dependent and now they can't
get a check from the government even
though they're independent so that I
think is what's happening Justin they
didn't even get the 504 meeting and of
course didn't get 1200 so I'm basically
I don't exist even though I've been
paying that's right they're stuck you're
stuck in the nothing in the in the
nether regions of the of the federal
government which is always an
uncomfortable place to be Justin I
appreciate the call we'll in Colorado
you're on the bench Pierce
well and thank you for taking my call so
my question for you was when you're
debating with liberals and how do you
handle their arguments coming from
emotion your arguments coming from fact
and not feel crazy
basically yeah well I wish I were
perfect at it I mean I I feel like I'm
I'm fairly good at it but there are
times when when I break and when I break
it's never good right it's always a bad
look the key is to remember that that is
the actual game here is to get people to
essentially lose it and if you lose it
then they can always make you look
flustered and make it look bad and
there's this famous BBC interview that
is gone around went from last year where
somebody just keeps needling me about
old tweets and eventually I'm like you
know what this is ridiculous and I just
walk off the set and this thing went
highly viral it was crazy
I love debating but why would I walk off
the set I let him go at me for like 20
minutes
and then I was like this is a complete
waste of time and I walked off the set
it was a bad look for me I should have
done it I should have just I agreed to
the interview it was dumb I should have
vetted at first but I didn't and so that
was a mistake
you know that sort of stuff does happen
that the key is to keep your cool
understanding that literally the entire
tactic is to make you lose your cool
that's a because the facts do not line
up with a lot of left-wing positions and
so the goal is to make you look as
though you're angry and then they can
say I'll look you're mad now you're
getting mad it's all teenage bullcrap
but it is successful in the world of
media so you know that it really is a
challenge and you just have to
understand what people are up to well I
really appreciate the call Jim in Austin
Texas you're on the bench before Jim
when we debate those that are on the
left they often end as vilifying their
own position albeit ingredients while we
on conservatives can look back on men
like Reagan and Milton Friedman and
still appreciate why does it often seem
that the less is committed to a
direction rather than a policy or a
position I mean I think that the reason
is because for the left the constant
goal is revision of the system this is
why they constantly this is why they
call themselves progressives because
whatever the system is the system must
be torn down it doesn't matter that we
have the biggest government in human
history right now in the United States
it doesn't matter that we have been
consistently moving in a leftward social
direction in the United States the goal
is that here's the thing left is amiss
based on a philosophy which is that
human beings are innately malleable
human beings aren't there's no such
thing as human nature
human beings are innately valuable to
the to the points the extent that people
on left claim that men can be women and
women can be men right that's how
malleable we are we are completely
malleable and that means that all human
shortcomings are not a result of human
nature all human shortcomings all
inequalities all failures are the
results of the system well the system is
always to be blamed for faults of human
nature and those faults never go away
that means the system has to be
constantly revised and constantly
changed and so for the left because they
will never reach their utopian system
because human nature does exist it does
in fact exist the goal is to constantly
tear down the system that exists in
favor of a new better system controlled
by people like them because if they
control human beings from the top then
they can finally change human nature
along the lines of which originally have
been changed this is when I've used the
phrase on the show Marxist materialism
this is the idea that economic
circumstance dictates how you're going
to act and this is the innate promise of
Marxism in a promise of Marxism is not
that you're gonna be more prosperous
it's not that it's going to be
incredibly fair it's that simply by
rejiggering the nature of the economy
you've changed the social circumstances
surrounding human beings and human
beings will have their heart of stone
replaced with a heart of flesh and
suddenly human beings will be better and
human beings will be different well that
means that when you look around society
and you see anything happening that is
bad that is the result of the system
it's not the result of individual
responsibility because individuals were
shaped by their environment so it's the
fault of the environment so all you have
to do is constantly be shouting at the
system and so that's why it's about the
direction the direction is always
tearing down the system it's why leftist
revolutions innately eat their own
because the person who is promoting one
form one second ago is now the person
who's in power and the person in power
is responsible for the system and the
system will always be bad because there
will always be flaws in human nature and
so that person has to be torn down now
it's why Robespierre will lead the
French Revolution and then find self
defined himself guillotine in a couple
of years later it's why Lenin will lead
the revolution and then Stalin will
basically push him down the stairs this
is the way that that all of this works
in leftism it's why you're seeing all
the same people who are promoting Martin
Luther King's actual policies and in
1968 with regard to race now those
people are declared racist by by the
newfangled intersectionality advocates
it's why you see people who are very
much in favor of a feminist stand in
favor of women being castigated as turfs
by people who suggest that women can
become men the revolution always has to
eat
the Revolution is ongoing and never ends
that that is why it's all about a
direction and about a specific policy
the moment you Wed leftism to a specific
policy then that policy will become
responsible for the innate human sin
that leftist refused to recognize exists
so so basically it's them running into
the brick wall of a utopia as possible
and so rather than taste the brick wall
at this area they just go to the other
side of the brick wall and keep hitting
their head against that side
that's exactly right instead of them
actually just recognizing that the
entire basis for their philosophy is
wrong human nature is exists it is not
malleable and human beings are going to
sin which would be the complete
destruction of their entire belief
system which is that human beings can be
completely changed by the system around
them instead of just acknowledging that
they're wrong about that they will just
keep tearing down the system the system
is it's always the system default which
means the system always can be torn down
Jim really appreciate the call
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
benton shapiro show if you did go ahead
and hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content